hi everyone uh today we are going to
show you in this short video how one of
our Affiliated lxms is uh going to uh do
the coding procedure for a Ford key fub
on site uh this is how it's actually
done in case you lost all your keys or
just want to have a spare set this is a
necessary procedure that requires a
spatial machine for all uh Ford key fobs
and transponder Keys uh if you have any
questions please comment below and and
uh we'll uh answer thanks for
watching hello everybody we're currently
programming a new key for a 2017 Ford
Explorer um we are resetting the car
erasing all the fobs and in turn we have
to program two keys so we lift up the
armrest and Slide the key right there
into the slot you just drop it right in
there and that that's where the
programming slot is and also if you lose
your your uh mean if your battery dies
in a fob and the car won't start because
it doesn't detect the key you drop it in
there so we're going to clear the
keys right now it's going to erase the
old keys off the
system current numbers zero it's telling
you to drop the key in the armrest box
which we
did hopefully it's going to detect there
we go that's the first key do we want to
learn another one yes we have to because
once you erase all the keys on a Ford
you have to program two keys so we're
going to put it head down right down
there in the
slot and insert the other one and I'll
wait for the beep for the click there we
go two keys learned that's it we're
going to remove the key from the
slot we're going to hit no and we're
going to attempt to put our foot on the
brake and start the car that's it 2017
Ford explore thanks for watching
guys for